Ukrainian civilians once more punished
by Russian missiles
the strikes here in the southern city of
separagia came a day after Russia
escalated its war with a devastating
barrage of Nationwide attacks
it prompted Ukraine's president to urge
the UK and six other powers to do more
to protect his skies
in London a British spy Chief used a
rare public speech to highlight the
kremlin's limitations as well as its
lethal force and we know and Russian
military commanders know
that their supplies and munition are
running out
Russia's forces are exhausted as Russia
runs down its stockpiles of Conventional
Weapons and with Vladimir Putin showing
no sign of backing down in your opinion
does the risk of Russia resorting to a
nuclear strike increase and has gchq
seen any tangible evidence of that being
prepared beyond the rhetoric I would
like to think that with our allies we
would have a good chance at spotting it
but of course there are never any
guarantees in in this space my view is
for the moment that Russian Russian
Doctrine and President Putin's approach
to this war would see that being a you
know hopefully a long way off
uh but I think we all need to be
concerned about the rhetoric
nuclear threats will likely be discussed
at a key meeting of NATO allies in
Brussels this week
the alliance is pressing ahead with an
annual exercise involving aircraft that
can carry nuclear warheads despite
heightened tensions with Russia it would
send a very wrong signal if we suddenly
now canceled a routine long-time planned
exercise because of the war in Ukraine
in typical fashion Vladimir Putin tried
to make out any nuclear saber rattling
was nothing to do with him even though
he's repeatedly alluded to his nuclear
Arsenal during this crisis
foreign
back in Ukraine there are even more
immediate concerns the Ukrainian
military wanted to show its troops
training close to the border with
Belarus
there are fears Bella Russian forces
might deploy in support of Russia's
invasion in what would Mark another
dangerous escalation
Deborah Haynes Sky News Brussels